hey everyone
welcome
individuality spirituality non-duality
again what we're doing in these videos
is that we are showcasing all of these
different
paths to that one
end and that way
we see the mountain from these different
faces we can draw
the different concepts that
help us pierce the veil and self-realize
this is extremely obvious individuality
the separate self that is egoic
is contracted it's suffering
because it's seeking happiness outside
while the well of honey is underneath of
the rock
it's the parable of the prodigal son
going outwards
and hitting a breaking point and then
turning inwards to the investigation of
the observer of the witness
of the experiencer of the i am-ness the
recognition
of the kingdom of god within
so that contracted egoic
separate entity of the individual
ends up like a sugar cube dissolving
it relaxes it releases
it expands and in the analogy of the
sugar cube it dissolves
into the oceanic
consciousness that contracted egoic mind
dissolves
into oceanic i am-ness
the infinitude of awareness
that is eternally being colored by
experience
the contracted egoic separate entity
realizes
the oceanic-ness and the eternity of
that capital s self of the i am-ness
that is being eternally colored
by experience
the individuality pierces the veil
in that second step of spirituality with
seeking and finding
that it is the blank sheet of paper
that is eternally being colored by
words it recognizes that it is the
oceanic-ness
that is eternal that is
constantly never endingly being
colored by the waves
the waves are the thoughts the
emotions the feelings the beliefs the
objects the experiences
and that contracted egoic separate
entity is completely
lost in those
now the juxtaposition as the spiritual
seeker
pierces the veil and finds that diamond
necklace already around their neck
that well of honey under the rock that
they create that juxtaposition
and they begin living in the i am-ness
they begin living in the infinite
consciousness and that infinite
awareness
that is being colored by the waves
by the words or by the clouds
you are the sky you are
the ocean you are the blank paper
or in the modern example you are the
blank
phone screen and the
blank phone screen is constantly being
colored by
applications by messages by emails by
phone calls
by calendar events
so in essence individuality to
spirituality
is like the contracted egoic sugar cube
of the separate self dissolves relaxes
releases expands
as it dissolves into that oceanic
infinitude of awareness and
consciousness and i
am-ness and that's the spirituality
that's the seeking that's the finding
and that's the piercing of the veil to
self-realization or god realization
so usually what happens is that
there is some sort of a tendency for
there to be a ah
excellent so god realization
self-realization
excellent
actually there's more there's more to
discern
there's more subtlety
to be the oceanic-ness and to
recognize the perfect crest of
every single wave
to live exactly in the pure
perfect indescribable nowness
this simply
this happening
and to ride
like the world's best surfers right on
the crest
and do it from the i am-ness from the
knowingness of the infinitude of the
eternity
not from the contracted separate self
that is egoic that is a finite
biological creature meh
what a miserable life the contracted
separate entity the biological creature
that's finite that's seeking happiness
externally
only gets one minute of bliss per day
you have a 24 7 well
of honey that is under the rock
of bliss and peace
the well of straight bliss and peace
pierce the veil self-realize so the next
layers of subtlety the next layers of
of surrender expose
and even more
subtle and even more formless
and even more
agentless and attributeless absolute
of the non-dual
perfection that this is
there's a rejection of the observer
there's a rejection of the i am-ness
once you gain a tremendous amount of
subtlety
to the very very most subtle
i am-ness there's a transcendence
of even the i am observer or awareness
to a place that is completely agentless
also expressed as metaphysical zero
whereas spirituality is a lot about
oneness and a lot about unity the
metaphysical zero
is that agentless
attributeless indescribable
perfection
and this is on a scale from the gross
of the individuality the separate self
that believes it's a physical biological
creature
and you gain a lot of subtlety when you
even
begin being a seeker and
piercing the veil and finding creating
that juxtaposition becoming
the observer the witness the infinite i
am-ness that is being eternally colored
by experience
so much subtlety so much subtlety
completely shattering the illusion
of fear and the illusion of death
the illusion of separation completely
shattering those
so massive amount of subtlety massive
amount of peace
and bliss completely causeless joy
completely imperturbable piece
and then even more subtlety even
more subtlety to recognize what is
completely agentless
what is completely attributeless
what is a metaphysical zero
simply that is
it just is it is perfect
it is indescribably perfect
all of these creation designs are
absolutely
perfect
and this is where the idea of there's
nothing to do
there's nothing to seek everything is
already
indescribably perfect comes from
and that's why simultaneity is key
a true level of simultaneity is able to
simultaneously
be the indescribable perfection
while also
recognizing that when they are
getting a bottle of water from a
convenience store
that they are not the level of
complete indescribable perfection where
they can't
even engage with
the cashier there to purchase their
bottle of water
so it's the ability to dynamically
simultaneously
ebb and flow across
all of these layers the non-dual the
spiritual
the individual and to deal with all of
the
8 billion
journeys of piercing the veil and
finding because
all of the different expressions are at
different
levels of piercing that veil
of self-realizing
of the god realization
of the well of honey that is under the
rock
of the diamond necklace that is already
around our necks
of the indescribable perfection
that is simply this
crest after crest
after crest of surf
this this
this the just
the awe for this
you